[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a number 92 sorry
for the delay on getting started we
are running into some difficulties with
the new odyssey platform and getting the
second stream running hopefully that
will
solve itself quickly but in any case
welcome back here we are here we are
okay
uh let's launch right in it's already
pretty late uh is there an evolutionary
connection to the deja vu experience
thank you both for your authenticity
much love to you both
um
yeah i've got two little stubs of a
hypothesis here one of them not ours in
any way which has to do with the fact
that the two sides of the brain process
the same information and in general they
don't
understand themselves to be processing
separately because the corpus callosum
unites things in some sort of
synchronized way but that a slight
desynchrony could result in something
arriving
in a way like it had uh like it was late
to the party and so the initial one and
the follow-on would not match up and it
would feel like you'd seen it before
i've never quite bought this one because
it seems like it's too much too short a
time scale right deja vu tends to be
about you know days weeks years
right down the road so
the
so that's the one that's not yours right
yeah um my hypothesis has to do with the
fact that it's also a very mechanistic
hypothesis yeah it's pretty approximate
yeah
um so
what i would say is what we must be
doing what we can infer from the way
life is and the way we experience it
imagine that you are walking through a
city that you know somewhat but you were
walking down a street that you've never
walked down before into a plaza that
you've walked into but not from that
direction you have to recognize it as
the same plaza so you're doing some sort
of interpolation where you have some
model of the plaza and you have some
idea what it would look like from a
slightly different angle
and so the point is that thing is a
detector for familiarity and to the
extent that you might walk into
something that would trip the detector
but not actually be the place you might
have the sense of i've been here before
and that something like that this uh
this feels very much in keeping with my
anecdotal addition to what you're saying
is that the last two moves that we've
made uh which would have been
uh
20 years ago from nr michigan to olympia
washington and then three almost three
years ago from olympia washington to
portland oregon
um all so
ann arbor and olympia are kind of
comparable in size very different in
feel but both college towns and uh
portland is is bigger
but it has it's also in the pacific
northwest portland is bigger ann arbor
is colder and hotter
both colder and hotter
culturally portland and ann arbor have
more in common olympia's kind of a
backwater
um but uh but the pacific northwest
stuff that anyway it doesn't matter um
in both cases um for quite a number of
years well aft after the move to olympia
and i'm still experiencing it um in
portland i'll go someplace
and be like oh i know this place like
now actually the the thing i'm
remembering is very precisely olympian i
can i can put where it is and i was
doing that with regard to walking around
olympia and finding myself someplace
going like oh right i didn't remember oh
no that's you know half a continent away
that was actually in michigan yeah um so
it
the quest that you know the prediction
if that
if
if it's that sort of misplaced
familiarity um is that this is a modern
artifact of the fact that we move into
very unfamiliar places sort of suddenly
as opposed to wandering into new spaces
and um we can thus trick ourselves our
brains can imagine oh you're just in the
place you've always been like no
actually i've taken quite a big leap
well i i think what you're saying
would be
that if you lived in some standard way
where you tended to be in places that
were actually likely to have been passed
through before that the detector
would even to the extent that it
misfired occasionally very quickly
correct to where you actually are yeah
and that having displaced yourself by a
thousand miles um its tendency to
uh fire and then not know what to do
because it can't correct to anywhere
might cause something like this yeah uh
i i believe there's some
some likelihood to that some novelty to
this so obviously the prediction of that
would be
that you know if you
interviewed
aboriginals in their ancestral habitat
and you said hey
what's your word for deja vu they might
not have one or know what you were
talking about yeah exactly
hi everyone thank you for your open
discussions i have a question in regards
to how safe blood transfusions are it's
a quick big question um because of how
it pans out with regard to blood from
copenhagen patients and blood from um
vaxxed versus unvaxed
i don't know the answer to this
i don't think i don't think anyone does
yep um
we have the same puzzle with
spike proteins that we've always had
which is we know that spike proteins are
dangerous from the virus
there is a
shell game played with spike proteins
from the vaccine which are not identical
to the ones from the virus because
they've been modified for a purpose two
purposes in fact they have an
anchor domain that's supposed to keep
them lodged in the membrane of the cell
that produces them and they've been
locked open rather than changing
confirmation when they hit
their target
and the question is does that actually
neutralize their toxicity and
let's just say there's enough damage
associated that probably it certainly
probably it doesn't do it perfectly yeah
um
so you wouldn't want to get spike
protein for all sorts of reasons just
because you're trying to get blood
you're not trying to get spiked protein
so
there's some hazard the question is how
quickly does the spike protein that
circulates decay from
um
from the blood that you would get from a
blood bank and
how long does it persist after an
infection and we don't know we don't
know
dark
i find myself needing to meet
vaccination requirements to attend class
fly home participate in university
sports and more is coming
isn't the case for mandating it based on
transmission laughable
my arr my uh
what risk reduction my absolute risk
reduction absolute risk reduction from
the vaccine is not very high
help me with the pros and cons do i lose
everything or risk being permanently
harmed with no one liable for something
that will not end covet if i get it and
call bs when this doesn't work told ya
maybe that could inspire some real
change
um
yeah this is i mean and they're gonna
this is something that many people are
living with right now right they're
gonna be a lot of questions like this
and we don't have answers
but
yeah i would say the absolute risk
reduction issue is
quite salient and there's a reason
presumably there's a reason that we are
doing
relative risk reductions
instead which
we've talked about before
the
obvious hazard to your life of not being
permitted to do what you need to do is
large and i would say it's very
frustrating that we can't talk about the
full range of things that would allow
you to get vaccinated and potentially
neutralize harms
that's where we're stuck yep
um
given the evidence of corruption of the
institute's institutions in regards to
covid are you more interested in hearing
out the issues with the 2020 election
after all the rewards from a corrupted
politics is greater than that of the
academy
so you get richard barris for a very
reasonable outlook on what went wrong
you know there's
there's so much potential corruption out
there and uh
i guess
i don't doubt that it's in places that
we haven't thought to look i haven't
thought to look and others have
um
and
at some level we all have to choose what
battles it is that we're fighting and um
although for instance
we
are
consciously
not
speaking about the continuing flow of
evidence that uh
that for instance ivermectin is
effective in prophylaxis against uh
kovid as much anymore because evidence
is out there and um
uh that's that's where we are um
there's just a lot there's just a lot to
talk about and that's probably not going
to be some place where we focus
i guess yeah i mean i will say more
generally i i am
increasingly frustrated at how
little consideration
most people especially people sort of in
charge of managing
our you know collective sense of how
troubled we should be
how little attention there is paid to
a generalized corruption that spreads
over everything that invades every
process and
um
has been very frustrating in the context
of covid
to effectively be continuing to talk
about the corruption of the academic
literature the political apparatus the
regulatory agencies and to be treated
funding agencies right corporations as
if we're suddenly alleging these things
in the context of covet and the answer
is no it was there before and all
indications are that it is continuing to
function in this context the amazing
hypothesis on the table is that it
suddenly stopped right right like that's
that's the unusual suggestion which is
not the one that we're making well it's
actually it's a sleight of hand because
the idea is if you weren't paying
attention to the degree to which
corruption had invaded the academy for
example and then suddenly you tune in at
the point we're talking about what the
academy produces with respect to kovid
it's like they're alleging someone has
gotten a hold of the academy and it's
like no the academy had been gotten a
hold of and it's been well documented
and the fact that you may not be aware
of how far that's gone doesn't mean it
wasn't happening all along our analysis
and analytical tools didn't change here
yeah they didn't yeah
yeah and that's um
you know really that's part of part of
the lesson of the book that we've been
reading excerpts from chapter by chapter
and we'll continue to through through
the publication date in september is
that um
using an evolutionary lens to understand
the landscape in which you live both
physically and socially
can arrive you at an understanding that
is impervious to the social machinations
of those around you and
the you know that doesn't mean it's
comfortable and that doesn't mean you
won't lose
friends uh that doesn't mean that you're
going to be able to extract yourself
from
some societal expectations even when it
really feels like they're not
appropriate for you
but having a set of analytical tools
that you can use in order to make sense
of your world and that you can share
with other people so that they can use
them so that people need rely on
authority as little as possible
and need to take other people's words
for things as little as possible and do
their own assessment for themselves
that's the goal here
possible vaccines lots of lots of these
questions today
um
except this is written in sort of a
a telegraphic style um
is it possible that vaccines increase
the catching or spreading of covet 19
given these pieces of
evidence that this person is saying
spikes in high vaccination rate
countries
um and anecdotally his parents had
coveted in october got the pfizer
vaccine in march and have coveted again
now
um
and they gave it to his sister's family
who are not vaccinated and
something bill i'm not sure oh
brother-in-law are now in hospital so um
that's just some anecdotal stuff along
with an observation that there's spikes
in highly vaccinated countries
maybe um
no let's just put it this way it is
possible right there is a mechanism it
has a name it's called antibody
dependent enhancement and
it has different ways that it can work
but essentially antibodies are molecules
that stick to things they stick to
things for which they are matched to the
extent that vaccines create antibodies
that are matched to
pathogen they are supposed to block the
functioning of the pathogen so that it
cannot bind the things that it would
typically bind to but they can do the
opposite they can change the
conformation of the spike protein or
they can
augment it by sticking in a particular
place that's sub-optimal and it can
cause an increase in transmission do we
know that that's happening we do not
know that it's happening but is it
possible absolutely and we should
absolutely be looking for it yeah
absolutely so i there are a couple of
other ade questions here that i thought
i would just try to get to since they're
in keeping
why doesn't the flu shot cause ade cause
antibody dependent enhancement how is it
different than the coveted vaccines
good question i don't feel
uh
well positioned to answer it i think
there are lots of i mean well but at the
second question is it's not and it's not
using an mrna platform it's using a
traditional platform right but uh that's
just one way let's put it this way if
the answer is that it is functioning
through
uh
t cells primarily rather than antibodies
then that would explain it but my guess
is their antibodies created in general
to the flu shot i don't know
um and so in principle could it do that
in principle probably it could unless
there are anti unless antibodies are
excluded but just don't know enough
about the flu shot to answer the
question yep
um
okay
what do you know so the answer to this
is going to be nothing really what do
you know about the compound uh i don't i
never know how to pronounce this can a
can of cannabidiol cannabidiol cbd what
do you know about cbd from the cannabis
plant a study found to be effective
against covin
um and i went i did
look at the study you can just show our
screen here for a minute zach um it's
it's a pre-print uh
cbd inhibits stars cov2 replication and
promotes the host innate immune response
but i have not had time inhibits
replication inhibits didn't i say that
inhibits starts coming to replication
and promotes the host and immune
response
um
but i have not had time to look at this
paper yet well that's interesting yeah
if it prevents replication that's uh
highly useful it's not just a
reduction in harm to the individual but
uh presumably a reduction in
transmission to others so yeah and of
course you know there's there's lots of
separated out cbd available on the on
the market now that a lot of people are
using and of course there are a lot of
pot smokers as well and you know it
it it paves the way for some sort of you
know going back and you know natural
experiments looking at uh looking at
whether or not pot smokers have lower
rates of true
um i know it's just a pre-print but did
you
was there a um
any indication of how effective and
what kinds of dosages i really i i
honestly just got the link out but i
have not looked um
a cohort of human patients previously
taking cbd had significantly lower
serious kobe 2 infection incidence of up
to an order of magnitude
relative to matched pairs or the general
population
or dude
we should say
uh i'll leave this i'll leave this tab
open that's all i'm going to promise the
one god drowning and stuff this is a
paper that somebody has pointed us to so
it's not like we've been through it um
and of course our enemies will like to
hold us responsible for it but
um anyway interesting well and okay
everyone on the planet should want
effective prevention of and treatment of
covet 19. yep
that should not be a controversial point
you would think everyone on the planet
should want as many possible avenues to
prevent and treat this disease as
possible regardless of where you fall on
any other question right right so um
does cbd work we don't know there's a
paper in preprint that suggests it might
cool
you know does giraffe p work i don't
know no one's tested that one yet if
someone says it does
cool be glad to see it you know do does
sitting on lunar rocks work cool like
anything really like
let's get everything possible out there
whatever whatever actually works
whatever right can be demonstrated yes
uh yes for those of you who weren't
paying close attention or who are eager
to misconstrue no i do not have any
evidence that drinking giraffe pee or
sitting on linda rocks is actually
effective in the transmission of in
preventing the transmission of
not that there aren't other valid
reasons to do it there are a lot yeah i
would say right yeah yeah i seem to
every time that i'm looking into the
right camera now zachary cleverly
switches which camera i'm on so that's
right i'm always looking
off screen like a confused cat
okay
is it
is it possible that adenovaxes
can assist
i don't even know how to interpret this
question honestly
um
something about hiv
and um adenovax and i've heard murmurs
of this but i don't know anything about
it i just don't know anything about it
okay yeah um
and
uh silver
silver as a
antiviral
again we've we've said before someone
thinks you know a few people seem to
think something like colloidal silver i
know nothing about it
um
okay
i feel like we already talked about ade
um
i'm gonna try finding something that's
not about
here we go
oh this is this is not a fun question at
all but it has nothing to do with covid
you ready it's genocide instead
wonderful yes
in the context of lineage selection and
ecological dominance i see a logic
natural law behind for example genocide
where is the threshold for that outcome
in the modern world there was a global
scale genocide inevitable
well global you can do this yeah
um
so first of all it depends what you mean
by global was it global scale yeah
that's what he says
so lineage selection
predicts that some lineage will
target other lineages
obviously we are all one lineage at one
level
and you don't really expect
that
you would expect maybe very large
lineages to go after other very large
lineages
the threshold is presumably a
um
cost
benefit analysis of
the degree to which
the size of one lineage's pie grows
at the cost of eliminating another
lineage
in the modern era
the algorithm is liable to be
the algorithm that individuals are
driven to this kind of
demonization of others which is
presumably the mechanism through which
this goes will be very poor because you
won't
anticipate things like what happens if
some population
has nuclear reactors collapses and those
nuclear reactors
you know melt down and explode
right we won't intuit that
so
there's that on the other hand countries
have
intelligence agencies who presumably can
do explicit calculations about things
which
might change things but i see no reason
that if we don't get in the road of the
instincts that cause lineage selection
to trigger people to do this that it
won't happen again at every greater
scale yeah and i mean i guess that's
that's it is that um
the way
that we talk about and invite and
encourage others to talk about the
evolutionary toolkit
is how can you best understand what the
forces are that created who you are
today such that you can override those
forces that do not actually have your
and your friends and the world's best
interests at heart yes and so lineage
selection is true and real and yes
absent any other
forces
uh it it could well lead to complete
obliteration of the species um but we're
humans and we can and must be better
than that we can we can override our
basis instincts and and we need to and
we do it all the time and that's the
thing every time you know if you live in
a cosmopolitan country which presumably
almost everybody who's watching this
podcast does the point is
you you go to the theater you go to the
market you hang out in the square with
people who don't look like you and
aren't so closely related to you and
you're not constantly looking at the
other people in the square who do look
like you and thinking hey maybe the
folks that don't look like us can't
defend themselves and we can take their
stuff right i mean we don't do that
right we get over it and frankly we
actually like it right
you know i've made this point before
the
united colors of benetton and i'd like
to buy the world of coke were [ __ ]
but that was advertisers tapping into
the fact that people actually like it
when they have camaraderie across these
yeah these lines of difference they feel
good about themselves and they feel good
about other people and so it's not like
this is some herculean effort to get
over these instincts it's like if in a
world where it is profitable to put
racism aside people will do it right
that's what we should be
creating is a world where it makes sense
to do it and then people will because
frankly it's just better yeah good
the wife and i are planning some
old-fashioned american road trips
plans to visit we have plans to visit a
bit of east and west coast do you have
any point of interest recommendations
for two nature lovers while visiting
portland oregon
there's so much here yeah there's a lot
of the whole pacific northwest is just
just extraordinary and um
uh you know we're only fairly recently
in portland and a considerable amount of
that time has been during coven um
but
um you know depending on when
to some degree depending on what time of
year you're here you know it's you kind
of probably don't bother in february
it's just not a
easy to get around moment it never gets
bitterly cold the way it does say in the
upper midwest but or it almost never
does
um but it's just it's unpleasant to be
to be out although uh you know here like
many places with um a lot of wet or bad
wet or bad weather um
the saying is there's no bad weather
there's only bad clothes
um but
you know the coast and there are a lot
of towns with different uh different
cultures and ethos along the coast and
mount hood
and just a number of parks along the
willamette river
and um you know within portland itself
we have forest park which is like 5 000
acres or something insane and then
washington park which is an order of
magnitude smaller but still 500 acres
and trying creek state park which is 700
plus acres so these are just giant parks
within the city i think forest park is
within the city limits but it certainly
abuts the city if not within the city
limits
um so you know in terms of in terms of
nature you've got those three giant
parks and you've got the willamette
running through the city and the
columbia hugging the northern edge
between oregon and washington
mount hood just an hour and a half to
the east northeast and the coast is an
hour and a half to two
to the west so you know just and you
know that's
that's not all by any means yeah i would
say one one caution sometimes the uh the
big parks in portland are a little
disappointing wildlife wise because
they're so uh full of english ivy which
for whatever reason has a bad impact on
the animal life that you're likely to
see um the willamette is pretty healthy
the river yeah yeah it's amazing um we
see a lot of bald eagles i've seen i saw
mink last week again
i've seen two osprey carrying fish
overhead in the last two weeks yeah i
have two actually and also i saw um
i saw a
turkey vulture depend defending a fish
from a crow
defending a fish from a crow yeah um not
far from here we saw some pretty good
stuff up at uh
near catherine creek on in the gorge the
gorgeous columbia river gorge is amazing
um
we talked a little bit about drive falls
which obviously is not right here that's
not in portland yeah so this is the
question specifically about portland
well yeah but i mean pacific northwest
you get bigger you know any of the
volcanoes are amazing and you know
adam's hood rainier helen's baker
farther north you know if you're going
farther north the san juan islands yeah
rainier is particularly dramatic yeah
and has a very good population of a lot
of a lot of wildlife
um
oh i we haven't spent much time since
we've been here but i had a local
photographer recommend the coast range
in terms of wildlife
yeah you know we i i we went swimming in
a river in the coast range last summer
yep us and the boys and the dog
um but otherwise i've really just gone
through over to get to the coast a
couple of times but yeah and i think
it's it's yeah everybody liked that
except a dog
oh yeah the dog hates going swimming in
the river oh just terrible yeah it makes
her too ecstatic that's what he doesn't
like about it that's right that's right
um and i guess um
you know right here in portland as well
as the willamette which really is right
here in the parks um
the japanese garden is glorious
um
it's totally glorious yup yeah
um
i'd like to take ivermectin preventively
but here's my hesitation the safety
record is based on annual and twice
annual treatments however the flccc is
recommending twice weekly doses for
prevention is there any data showing
that it is safe to take ivermectin that
frequently for months on end nope nope
there isn't there is not and we've
talked about this before i think when we
in and and um our eclipse guy clipped it
when we were asked to steal man the case
um against
ivermectin we specifically um
and like the concern that i have
specifically is on gut microbiota yeah
um because it's so broad spectrum
but that's it's really it's it's like
the concern that i haven't and the
problem is we don't have the data yeah i
i don't think it's a minor concern but i
think
you know
what we have is a lot of bad options
and yeah
the higher the dose required
the worse the option is exactly
okay so i'm just remembering um because
we're doing this new thing now that um i
also have a question from the discord
server this week so i'm gonna ask the
one next question here and i'm gonna go
find that because i forgot it again i
think i forgot it last week too
um
gender id disorder i think is what this
stands for gender id disorder says the
mind is the issue and the solution is
therapy
while gender dysphoria says the mind is
fine it's the body that's the problem
that's an interesting frame that is an
interesting frame yeah
um this shift doesn't seem scientific
but ontological
also true
if the issue concerns the essence of a
right mind wouldn't compelling pronouns
be imposing religious beliefs on people
that's interesting
i'd never thought to frame
either and you know this doesn't
represent all sides but either of these
particular sort of philosophical
approaches
this way and
if someone thinks that that's not an
accurate framing i'd be very interested
to hear it
but
i think it's a it's a framing definitely
worth
spending some time yeah i mean i think
the way that i've talked about it and
the way i i'm actually in the middle of
writing something about
issues around this um
is that they're you know it's a it's a
mismatch right that you know under in
those very rare cases
where there really does seem to be a you
know a dysphoria
um
i don't you know i don't say the mind is
fine the body is the problem but that
there is you know there's an underlying
you know and
putting aside those rare cases that are
actually intersex those slightly more
common cases of trans without being
intersex
um
it's not that the you know that either
one is fine and the other one isn't good
it's that there is a mismatch that
somehow during development the
complexity of development after the
binary of sex
um caused the
caused
i mean i guess i was just gonna say like
how do i i guess i do say it as
the brain understands a different
reality than what the body reveals okay
but um
mind you
i'm just riffing here i think this is a
useful exploration yeah but here's the
place it goes it seems to me
let's put adults aside for the second
right
the problem goes back to what we were
talking about in the main
part of the program which was
the
highly
software-based nature of being a human
and the point is if
the
the body is fine the mind is the problem
version
is what one takes seriously
then
the point is for somebody who's very
young the ability to change the software
is actually part of what they're
involved in it is the upgrading of your
software that childhood is about
and so the idea that we are suddenly
going to start altering the bodies of
children oh yeah right makes no sense
what this suggests is that
if you were to choose between these two
models
right this suggests that the mind is the
thing to change
is
actually
liable to be better in most cases
because the mind is built to be changed
yes ah now i see where you're going
that's very good yes and that you know
that
that prevent that presents a conundrum
that potentially can be solved
i guess the objection i was going to
have is
if we're talking about doing anything to
children i'm sorry i'm out like i i
don't i'm i'm
i'm not interested in talking about you
know reconciling the stated beliefs of
children with their um you know obvious
phenotype
because children childhood is that time
of exploration and but so let's talk
about adults so let's talk about a 20
year old well hold on so what i would
say what i get out of this if you apply
this model the basic point is in the
case of children i'm not necessarily
saying that there's anything to do but
the basic point is because the mind is
coming to discover who you are and who
it wants to be and it's writing that
program that the and you know this fits
with the fact that lots of people who
have gender dysphoria just have it go
away they don't end up as gender
dysphoric adults so allowing that
process to play out is the best thing to
do for the person right and that sounds
more like it's not gender dysphoria it's
gender exploratory
yep and maybe those two things need to
be separated so the point is if you
arrive in adulthood and you remain
gender dysphoric then
whatever options are
on the table are really yours to choose
from within reason
but the idea that because adults should
have the right to choose these things to
reconcile a mismatch doesn't imply
anything about what should be going on
with children and that's the really
disturbing disturbing thing that is
absolutely true
um
yes so i
don't know where the error is but i
cannot find the discord question i think
because it's been coming in from another
account and i don't have that saved yet
so if if the mod
can text me if that's possible the um
the discord question for this week such
that i will just turn off airplane mode
and i will see it then
if when it comes in
that would be useful and i will answer
that when
when it does come in okay
does jealousy serve a useful purpose
should we strive to rid ourselves with
this emotional response or does it have
some utility
utility is all too obvious in some ways
um so think think about let's take the
simplest simplest version of this
male sexual jealousy right so males who
are
prone to
fear
and scenario build around the infidelity
of their mates are clearly involved in
an exercise designed to discourage
cuckoldry right and evolution whether
you should care about cuckoldry or not
evolution cares about it very deeply
because of course what could possibly be
more expensive than taking what limited
child rearing time any adult has and
directing it at the raising of someone
else's child who
vanished and is unknown to you and
especially when it happens as the result
of the deception of one's most intimate
partner uh you know there's certainly
lots of reasons you just look at me like
i just like to point out this is not
what we were fighting about this week
absolutely not um
but
the point is
you don't have to you don't have to know
very much about evolution to see why
selection would have programmed men to
be very troubled by this possibility and
that this is a issue built into being a
mammal and the reason it's built into
being a mammal is because for mammals
copulation and birth are widely
separated in time which makes it much
harder to know for certain so certainty
of paternity drops and you get the
evolution of behaviors in which men
follow
or males follow females around in order
to be more certain
so anyway the point is yeah kelsey is an
adaptive emotion
male sexual jealousy is the easiest one
to understand the reason that males and
females feel differently about sexual
infidelity versus emotional infidelity
should be pretty clear too because the
risks that males experience versus the
risks that females experience
are predictably different this is why
females tend to fear things like
abandonment males
tend to fear sexual infidelity um all of
this stuff falls so naturally out of
just simply tracking what an
individual's genes probably should care
about if they're trying to get into the
future um that you know
it it's a it's a pretty it's a pretty
simple puzzle to sort yeah i mean i do
think there are there are modern
instantiations of jealousy which are
harder to interpret but of course that's
basically the hallmark of modernity
right so i'm thinking
um
i
i've read
i don't know an article or a short story
or something this week in some magazine
um
about a woman um
who was unable to get pregnant who
really desperately wanted a kid and
this is a sort of story that most
moderns have heard tell of before but
the woman who's trying and cannot
conceive when she sees pregnant women
when she sees women with babies when a
friend tells her that she's pregnant
um
she seethes
rather than you know especially when
it's a friend she's just so mad at
herself for not being
happy for her friend but she can't
muster it
and um you know that i can't
we're all we're all familiar with this
even if we've never experienced it
ourselves
but i mean i think i think most people
will
recognize that as a framing that some
people experience
um as
as being common enough to almost seem
like yeah that's a kind of a human
response right like no one blames the
woman in this case but it does seem
a little mysterious to me i don't think
it's so mysterious i mean we got to
paint the scenario a little
more cleanly to know whether it makes
any sense in this case but
if a woman
wants a child that's obviously easy to
explain evolutionarily
and if she doesn't have one but wants
one then there are a bunch of things
that might be true that she could do
something about and that her jealousy or
at least her dismay might cause her to
some of its envy rather than jealousy
maybe or i don't know it's a little bit
of a distinction right but nonetheless
let's say there's some negative emotion
that causes the woman to focus on this
and instead of feeling joy on behalf of
her friend she feels um
uh troubled yeah and can't let it go
right well that's going to be the crux
isn't it it's they can't let it go it's
they can't let it go and so let's say
for example that she has
no partner
right
it might but you know now you're making
now you're making it too easy to no i'm
just going to say there's a list of
things okay in the case of no partner
she might be motivated by the negative
emotion that comes with not having a
child to lower standards frankly right
so it may be that and that could change
yeah but i mean the specific situation i
was talking about is someone who's mated
and trying to get pregnant and can't get
pregnant so there's some like there's
some it appears to be but i thought this
is where you were going and like i mean
i get we can do this all over the place
we can all do you know play out all the
different lines
but um i thought where you were going to
go just then but you can't let it go is
um
trying
can't
likely to be
one or the other of the people who are
trying to make a kid's
responsibility even though they have no
you know they have no ability to change
that thing
uh and so dwelling and really figuring
out okay i really really really want
this kid and
oh [ __ ] it's me
what do i do or
it's not me right if it's not her right
not me that's exactly what do i do then
how much do i want a kid
and how much do i want the guy i'm with
who doesn't seem to be able to give me a
kid right which again fits with the
change in standards it may be that she's
happy with the guy but it doesn't end up
with a kid and if it's him then
replacing him might result in a lower
quality guy and a kid so
the basic point is
you know you got a problem if you can't
figure out some way in which the
negative emotion could possibly lead to
a change in behavior that then
potentially augments uh fitness but i do
think that the the crux there in um and
what you and what you began to explain
and then we were talking about is the is
negative emotion causes you to slow down
and focus and i can feel it can go
pathological like you can just dwell and
dwell and dwell and dwell and not escape
from it and and be learning nothing
but in general uh modernity including
several branches of psychology would
have us immediately flee from any sense
of negativity you know any discomfort is
bad any you know reminder of anything
that's ever bad ever bad has happened to
us is bad and actually this is this is
backwards right and so no we don't want
to swing the pendulum all the way to the
other side and you know find ourselves
in the pits of despair and consideration
of everything that's wrong with us or
our lives or whatever all the time
um but spending long enough there
that you can't escape from your own
self-defense mechanisms and can figure
out what that negative emotion actually
might have to offer you
um as a way out of the conundrum you
find yourself in is
presumably the adaptive advantage yeah
and even if it doesn't cause you to
consciously recognize something it could
cause you to get antsy in a relationship
that
doesn't need to be a conscious
recognition yeah
can you be fat and fit studies conflict
um
gotta define fat for that one yeah right
i would say it's that's exactly right
you can definitely be
bulky but
and different you know people from
different
lineages will have different typical
body types too yep right and so you know
fat
fat for a masai is going to look very
different than fat for an inuit and
yeah i've ever seen a fat massage but
well exactly right and like that's
that's taking too obvious and easy an
example because um you know if
if your people whomever they be hearken
from a land where radiating heat was the
most important thing
uh then having a bit more fat may
actually interfere
more quickly with other physiological
and anatomical functioning yep actually
whereas if your people hearken from a
place where for many many many
generations what has been needed is to
conserve heat
then having you know certainly having
some fat on your frame is likely to be
uh easier to accommodate anatomically
and physiologically than um than if
you're from closer to the equator
there are a lot of links that i haven't
had time and it's hard in this
mechanism here that we have
to
to click on them so i'm not i'm not able
to click on these
um
what is your take
on evolution where humans are taking
risks via the nuclear chain reaction
think manhattan project or
agi gi uh artificial general
intelligence oh yeah
okay what's your take on evolution where
humans are taking risks via nuclear
chain reaction think manhattan project
or agi that may cause mass extinction
how does that fit into self-interest i
was punctuating the sentence wrong
before okay well there are two things to
say one we are bound not to intuit very
well the outscale risks that come from
things like uh
nuclear chain reactions let's say in a
reactor right a reactor may be a pretty
they're not as clean as people say they
put out radioactive
material as a matter of course but
in terms of the really heavy stuff they
don't release it until they release it
catastrophically
and so they seem clean short-term if you
don't live right downwind of them
that you know the net cleanness is not
intuited because you pretty much assume
that they're going to work rather than
assume a
natural rate of failure
so we don't intuit
things like reactors or what will happen
if i build a bunch of these bombs
because that enemy
is scary to me
right we don't intuit what could happen
and then um there's another
uh
what was the other
part of this agi
oh no it wasn't it wasn't the agi thing
um
it was
then there's the perverse incentive
aspect of this no it's all right we got
it okay um it's the perverse incentive
aspect which is
let's say that nuclear reactors are a
bad deal net
because the cost to humanity is actually
greater once you
realize that the
all the isotopes they produce have to go
somewhere and that the likelihood of
failure is going to spill some into the
environment and that it will have these
costs
right so let's say that they're
net bad but let's say
that you are running a corporation that
profits from the production of power
using these reactors and that because a
lot of the
harm is externalized you do not pay that
price and it's profitable right so
evolution may
correctly
cause a person in the position
to govern such a corporation to see the
production of more reactors as positive
even if the net impact of those reactors
is negative and evolutionarily that
person should
uh probably favor that behavior so
anyway those two things
very good
okay god there's so many questions
sunscreen is an artificial compound made
by the petrochemical industry should i
let this product interfere with my
natural interaction with the sun even if
it results in sunburn
so we've talked about sun sunscreen and
sunburn a fair bit and it's in our book
and i think we even may have read an
excerpt from it um
regardless of where it's from
um and if i mean they're like the zinc
zinc sunscreens aren't
aren't using petrochemicals inherently
physical it's just a physical barrier so
nobody uses those anymore but
really i don't think so i don't see
people with zinc noses so often yeah i
guess not um
yeah i feel like some people must but um
and it used to be sort of a badge it was
like warpaint for surfers
um
but uh and skiers um
i wouldn't avoid it because it's from
the petrochemical industry i would avoid
it because it's bad for you
and um and we've talked about we've
talked about this lots of other places
but um
moderating your sun exposure
behaviorally in so far as is possible
and with clothing rather than by
applying um
applying sunscreen um that may well do
damage to you
not only because of what it's made of
but also because it's actually limiting
the value of getting sun on your skin
including
what that can do for you with regard to
producing vitamin d is going to be going
to pose long-term health costs and
actually
not enough sun exposure is a very large
health risk a large health risk can very
likely in people who live sufficiently
far north or south
so you've got
prevents natural exposure to the sun
which can create vitamin d and vitamin d
is very protective against things like
covid and flu
chemicals in sunscreen can cross into
the blood and have unknown
consequences and
behavioral
uh alterations even very slight
behavioral alterations can prevent
sunburn we as we've talked about very
short breaks in the shade seem to reset
yeah the skin sun exposure so yeah i
would say there's lots of reasons to
worry about
um the seemingly elegant solution of
sunscreen
indeed
um given the importance of viral load
can we install ventilation systems to
exchange fresh air at a sufficient rate
to flush viral particles outside where
they'll die not from militant moderate
yeah
yeah we should be working on hvac
systems that do this that both catch and
and and do this and in fact the
third i think um post of mine on natural
selections um specifically gets into
this talking about um how you know
respiratory infections in hospitals went
up at the point that we started
enclosing them and using mechanical
ventilation as opposed to fresh air that
is being able to having windows and
large rooms that had open i mean yeah
large volume rooms with large windows
that open opening windows opening doors
having air flow is the thing that
reduces respiratory infections and it's
going to work on kovid and
um and we should be doing this
yes
um on the other hand there's also
especially in the winter and the summer
the problem is such a system
will counteract whatever climate control
is happening so yep there are downsides
that will drive up the price of medical
care uh it will make it harder to
maintain a good temperature in these
buildings and there are other solutions
that will work potentially too right
like an hvac system that simply
sterilizes the air that passes through
it either through drying or through
ultraviolet light exposure so there are
lots of things we can do so that would
work
in term that would poten that has the
potential to work
to kill the virus
there are presumably unknown benefits
many benefits that we do not yet
understand
of having actual fresh air flow through
a space well i think that's true i mean
even just things like
um reducing the consequence of the
off-gassing of all of the stuff in the
hospital or whatever exactly um i mean
just like just anecdotally right like we
have the experience of having been in
this heatwave for
a few days and this morning i woke up
it's like i was actually cool and for
two nights now we'd slept with the ac on
which we all hate
and i you know threw open all the
windows right away and just you know the
air quality in the house seemed to
improve dramatically and we have got a
high quality hvac we got an air filter
all house air filter like it's you know
we're not we're not breathing in spores
when the ac is on but
it just dries out the air and it makes
your throat sore and it it's just it's
just not as good for you yep
just not as good um creepy possibility
of the algorithm it wasn't listening to
your fight and inferred something about
your current mindset from your recent
browsing habits
i don't know i'm pretty much always just
looking at what could go wrong
i mean i wasn't looking for pool boys
oh no
terrible
ah and it knows we don't have a pool
there's that pool down slope wow this is
just catastrophic is it yeah i i think i
think you've been through worse
true yes today yeah today yeah yeah it's
got to go on twitter
um oh okay here we go have you read or
seen david fuller's latest pieces about
his concerns about you being in a
confirmation bubble about covet 19. much
love from a concerned listener
um yeah
that all
what more is there to say
i mean there there
there is a lot more to say but basically
um
there's been very little careful
scientific pushback
uh there's been a lot of social pushback
and what we have said privately to
people is this feels very post-modern it
feels very familiar
it feels very much like there's a social
universe
and a set of social conclusions that
people insist that we must come to
and
trying to figure out what is actually
true
um
should not interface with that social
universe nor does social pressure change
what is actually true
and so we have made a conscious decision
to not be talking about it as much
anymore absent big changes and what we
understand to be true
we are not going to play defense we are
not going to respond to
critiques that don't have new
information in them and the people
making them know what uh what that means
and um
there's just a lot
of evidence that continues to grow that
suggests that the position that we have
laid out both in what we wrote and what
we have said on many previous episodes
um holds and if that changes if anything
about that reverses we will absolutely
come to um to to you our listeners
well
now we're stuck in a bind right because
people will say
the uh there's lots of little things
here no it's not little things there's a
great big study
just been released the together trial
which says iremectin has no effect on
kobit whatsoever
except that's not what it says even the
study says it has an effect but it's not
significant but if you look at the way
the study was done it was absolutely
designed to fail it was given on an
empty stomach it was it recruited people
late in the disease it recruited people
who were either old or had comorbidities
yep and then you and then you see the
way it's reported right you know the la
times reports this study with the
picture of who donald trump donald trump
donald trump have to do with iron
machine absolutely nothing so you know
it's just one social play after another
and we don't even have the study what we
have is the punch line the supposed
punch line of the study from a slide
deck the study hasn't even been reported
in a preprint right so this is
um this is
clearly a
political ploy yeah um so we're not
going to respond to those things and
we're also not going to point out as
much
you know or or perhaps at all when you
know further evidence continues to
support the efficacy of prophylaxis for
instance
right right it's it's not
you know we're not
we're just not going to continue beating
this drum and i feel like
so many people have been in this
position we're not
caving and we're not playing defense and
we
hope that we're wrong about some of the
things that we are seeing in the adverse
events signal
but it doesn't seem that we are
yeah i guess one last point i would make
as long as we're going to talk about
this
i am deeply frustrated with david um
david
amplified the better skeptics project he
came to me privately and talked it up he
apparently suggested one of the referees
for the project so he had an important
role in how it unfolded and then at the
point that it went through our stuff
meticulously something like 44 claims
that we had misrepresented they found
three in which there was some indication
one of them we should probably come back
to at least but nonetheless the point is
he amplified the process right i thought
this is a dangerous way to do this it's
prone to several different kinds of bias
that i don't see
protect against in it and i was very
concerned
about you know a process that
um
you know incentivized instead of people
having skin in the game it incentivized
them to go nitpicking and
and all of this but anyway in the end it
gave us not a totally clean bill of
health but a remarkably clean bill of
health in light of how much um landscape
and how many complaints uh certain
people had made so
given
that that process concluded and that
that process does say something about
the quality of what we've been doing
here on dark horse didn't david have
some obligation to say well
you know here's the process that i
suggested might evaluate this and here's
the conclusion which is not what he did
he actually circumvented it and
frankly i resent it which david knows
because i've said it to him
all right
the discord question the question from
the discard server this week is
what can evolutionary lens teach us
about adhd
is it an adaptation a mismatch having
been done the person asks the person
continues having been diagnosed in an
early age i am now looking for solutions
outside of medication and just so just
to be clear i'll pose the question again
and let you riff on this um people on
either of our patreons
can join the darkhorse discord server
and then each week
some group of them
vote on which question that has been
posed they most want us to answer so we
answer one of the questions that comes
off the darkhorse discord server every
week and again this one this week is
what can an evolutionary lens teach us
about adhd is it an adaptation or
mismatch or what
um all right so
as always we need to be as careful as
possible because we're talking about a
diagnosis of something and i must say i
am i don't remember the specifics but i
am certain that i was diagnosed with
adhd at some late point as people were
grasping for explanations for my
odd interaction with school he's so
problematic so problematic i have a
feeling that my odd interactions with
school had a lot to do with the fact
that school really really sucked it
traumatized me a little bit and it took
me a while to get past it but yeah
school should be diagnosed with
borderline personality disorder yeah it
was uh it was not a learning disorder as
my brother says it was a teaching
disorder um but okay so the point is
this do i believe
do i believe in adhd i think at the end
of the day i believe that there are some
small percentage of the people who have
been brought under that diagnosis that
probably do have an actual disorder and
that the rest are probably suffering
from a mismatch between a very very
stupidly constructed environment and
their particular
predilections right you're not designed
to be sitting in a chair you're not
designed to be sitting in a room with a
bunch of other people facing the cave
wall as some authority scratches
abstractions on it it's not the way this
is supposed to work and so the fact that
it works for some people
cool the fact that it doesn't work for
some other people is not necessarily an
indication that those other people are
badly structured right and i could say
the same thing about
dyslexia right do i have dyslexia well
if there is such a thing i definitely
have it but given that reading is so
brand new how can we say that there's a
defect that comes from the fact that a
certain number of people aren't as good
they're not good enough at getting the
symbols from the page into their mind in
the correct ordering right that you know
that could just be a bell curve of
signal processing in which the price of
ink and paper has caused us to choose a
font size that puts some fraction of us
in a category where we're just not above
some threshold of acuity right like that
doesn't sound like a disorder to me
right that sounds like a varying
variation so it sounds to me like you've
got a serious case of font anger
um yes i've got a font of anger over the
ironic diagnosis of dyslexia which i
frankly don't believe in and it's not
i'm not against having defects i've
definitely got a color deficiency that's
a defect right i don't mind but um but i
do think that there's something awfully
opaque about the way medicine goes
around um wagging its diagnosis hammer
at stuff
right it diagnoses pain as a malady in
and of itself like that definitely
should have stopped at the point that
darwin explained how natural selection
works
um
and you know adhd do you have it you
might it's also possible that the
pharmaceutical industry decided they
would like you to have it because they
have a solution for it and that solution
is speed or something
um and if you're in that category where
you've been brought under a diagnosis so
that somebody can justify writing a
prescription that somebody would like
you to have because it's profitable for
them to sell it then by all means get
away from those people right figure
something else out and it may involve
rearranging the way your life works just
so that your
environment is a better match for your
mental structures right that's that's
the thing yeah and i guess
final point it is amazing it is amazing
if you just pay attention if you vary
one thing at a time and you pay
attention to the inputs in your world
and what the result is what the
consequences for your body and your mind
and your psychological well-being it's
amazing what you can find is actually
affecting you and cure just by virtue of
changing that parameter when you
identify it so
anyway don't give up hope and don't
listen too much to people you know who
are too eager to write you a
prescription because um a lot of those
people have ulterior motives
good nice rant thank you i like that
i enjoyed that
it's good
um
[Music]
a few questions a few people have
written and asked me about the
white-tailed deer do we want to do that
um yeah we could talk a little bit about
it okay so this this version of the
question is is it true that cobit cannot
be driven extinct due to animal
reservoirs
which is a
excuse me a reference to this finding
that came out sometime this week um that
some crazy huge number like 30 to 40
percent of whitetail deer in the us um
well it was from certain sample
populations but they extrapolated to the
us are they not uh there's definitely an
implication but um but let's just have
tested positive for for antibodies there
it is
well so let's let's talk about this
first of all there is a lot of panic
over the fact that lots of creatures
have tested positive for sars kovi too i
wouldn't worry about most of them okay
so we've had and we've had it
transmitted to
big cats we've had it transmitted to
both cats and dogs
domestic cats we've had transmitted to
um apes in the zoo basically zoo animals
and domesticated creatures have caught
it but there's a big difference between
catching it and being able to transmit
it to another creature like within your
species and then another difference
between that and being able to transmit
it back to a human which that last step
is actually the most likely in some
sense if it caught it from a human i
would say so yes
but that said
we really are not guaranteed we really
only have two
species in which we have seen something
that
looks like
human disease right the ability to
transmit it readily etc and those are
minks and ferrets right and one instance
literally a single individual mink that
has been found in the wild with the
disease i believe with the virus itself
not just the antibodies so i'm not 100
sure of that but in any case otherwise
it's farms right and pet fairies farms
and the the mink farms and pet farts and
the mink that was found with it was near
a farm so it's not an independent thing
so
is sars kobe 2 out there in some way in
animal reservoirs that prevents us from
driving it extinct yeah maybe
right we got minks and ferrets which we
can deal with because they're in farms
we've got lots of individual cases where
an animal has picked it up and it hasn't
circulated in the population those
aren't serious yet they could certainly
become serious but they aren't
um and this continues to evolve
right the virus continues to evolve and
manifest differently right and i should
point out that the mink ferret thing
is very likely related to the very
probable lab leak right and the point is
ferrets would likely have been a study
subject in gain of function research it
may have been passaged through ferrets
because their ace2 receptor is very much
like ours so
in any case yes
and minks and ferrets are close
relatives yes and they're so the ace2
receptors of the
uh mustelids are minks mustangs yeah of
of that whole that clade of mammals is
all very similar to humans that's why
they are model organisms used in things
like unit function experiments yep and
we should be looking at other closely
related critters uh skunks are a
possibility but
um they're not must are they they're
just outside so it's an arbitrary
distinction they used to be mysterious
and now they've been moved but they
haven't gotten it's the stripes isn't it
they're excluded on the basis of the
stripes i couldn't say no
that's not how systemics work but okay
let's get back to the deer
when i first heard about this study on a
deer i thought oh this is the worst
conceivable news because
this really does look like a widespread
epidemic within white-tailed deer in
which case there's there is no chance of
eradicating the virus
i wouldn't say that but i would say it
makes it just got
much
harder yeah um
that said
uh so my first thought was
worst possible news my second thought
was
i'm not even sure i believe that this is
true
and i thought maybe this was the result
of a coronavirus that circulates in deer
that has resulted in antibodies that are
triggering the test but it's not really
a new thing okay nope the study was
better than that it definitely tested
samples from after the cobia pandemic
and before the coveted pandemic and with
a couple of exceptions that are likely
to be
false positives the triggering is all
post-pandemic
so it does look like something now is
the antibody
test detecting
animals that are or have been infected
and have not had disease there's still
something strange about this did
was there
a
non-symptomatic or so lightly
symptomatic pandemic in deer that got a
foothold so quickly from human infection
something is not entirely seems not
entirely likely about this but
possible
is it possible the antibodies
are reacting to something covet like in
the environment without the infection
that seems unlikely that so many would
trigger a test so anyway let's just say
worst case scenario is that this
actually represents
sars kobe 2 infecting populations of
deer and the deer are giving it to each
other enough that we can detect it in a
large fraction of something like 40 of
samples in the michigan population
um
does that mean we're stuck with sars
kobe 2 forever
uh it could mean that on the other hand
i would say we are stuck with rabies
right yeah but
we have rabies well under control in the
western world
right
yeah it is both well under control and
for those of us who do work that puts us
at risk of a high risk of exposure there
are vaccines there are vaccines and we
have a program for dealing with the
human interface with animals that can
carry rabies and so anyway every so
often somebody dies of rabies right but
if every so often somebody died of covid
um that would be
a very tiny harm compared to a
uncontrolled circulating
uh pandemic so so i do think we need to
start drawing a cleaner line between can
we drive it absolutely extinct which
would be wonderful i'm not convinced
that if it's in whitetail deer
circulating that it's beyond the
possibility right in fact
there are a lot of ways that could go
but uh but anyway even even if we found
if we drive if you drove it out of the
human population and it remained in the
deer population there are various things
there are various levels of commitment
that we could put to the problem and
address it
but even if we didn't
if the point was well we're kind of
stuck with it because it's permanently
in the deer and we decide we can't do
anything about that
um then the answer is well maybe this
could be so well managed like rabies
that it is effectively not in the human
population right that the interactions
with it are so rare that it's
effectively not uh
not circulating oh i see that's
interesting yeah because rabies remains
um much more of a problem for some other
species than it does for us yep yeah
yeah um so anyway i would say look i
still i still have seen nothing that
says it can't be driven it's extinct if
the deer studies it sounds like you
you're still agnostic but you're leaning
towards that deer study
seems to likely be
my first
thought was it's gonna be flawed and the
flaw will be easy to spot and that's not
what i saw yeah your study looks well
done okay um that's so more likely but
there's still something odd about the
story so this thing
came to
north america in early 2020
must have leapt to deer very quickly
evolved enough capacity to move between
them and now a higher percentage of deer
than humans have been exposed right
i still will not be surprised if there's
something wrong here but i don't i there
is there is nothing in the paper that
indicates a poorly done study fair
enough all right
cats
are known to produce a parasite that
causes humans to become addicted to them
is this how crazy cat ladies are formed
yeah i don't think this is true
cats are known to um
sometimes be afflicted with a parasite
uh that uh that that what it can cause
some mental
some loss of mental acuity i can't even
find the words i think it's actually a
disinhibition thing
that's not just in
the cats you think it's in the people
yeah i thought it had some mental stuff
no it does but it's like a disinhibition
thing so it's like
alcohol
yeah i mean alcohol without without the
impact on
you know perception or reaction time as
far as i know but yeah i this this is me
working from memory from years ago
plus once in a while
um
yeah so this is just a
funny yes they do seem to um become
addictive
cats do but we have no evidence it's a
parasite
all right we have evidence that the cats
are a parasite it's just
a lovely parasite yeah
the american academy of pediatrics put
out an article suggesting that the
masking of child caregivers won't have
an impact on children's speech and
language development because there's no
known study on masking impacting a
child's speech and language development
is this capture or am i missing
something yeah i saw this this is this
is quite a feat of um linguistic verbal
acrobatics
um
but it's also prescriptive
what's that because it suggests that if
we can prevent anyone from doing a study
that demonstrates harm to children from
the masking of their caregivers
again there won't be any harm it's
exactly the same thing over and over and
over again yeah no evidence
no evidence yet exists means there can
be no evidence of harm means no evidence
means no harm i think the way to put it
is this oh my god
absence over and over and over again the
same sense of evidence means hey look
over there
yeah no but absence of evidence doesn't
mean hey look over there absence of
evidence means hey we're planning a flag
on this yeah we now know for sure that
this thing that we're telling you to do
is a hundred percent safe like really do
you well there aren't any studies saying
otherwise are there and we're not gonna
let any studies happen and like you you
wouldn't in this case you know you
wouldn't why because uh you don't
intentionally put children through that
hell yeah
yeah i mean
how could a professional group of
pediatricians and you know it was
probably an intern who wrote that
article whatever but
how can people whose professional life
is based on
growing children into functional adults
with this by maximizing health
conclude
that not seeing other people's faces
early in childhood
is fine
and there won't be any harm
and
it's not even like the proposal is
well you know what if kidney function is
impaired like yeah i don't i can't
imagine an effect on kidney function but
language development
all of us read lips like even those of
us with no hearing impairment whatsoever
we all read lips yesterday
in oregon or at least in multnomah
county i think all of oregon we went
back to mandatory mass mandates inside
so yesterday for the first time in a
couple of months i was
yelling
at the butcher behind the meat canner
and he was yelling back at me because we
could not understand that what i
actually said was i want a tri-tip and
he was like do we have tri-tip like i
just want a tri-tip please and you know
we were laughing about it and you could
tell we were laughing because we were
actually laughing so you could see it in
our eyes
but we're like yeah we're back here
where we can't communicate where
miscommunication is rife and we better
be gentle with one another because
suddenly we're back to where we cannot
in any way just
read the bottom half of a person's face
and know what they mean so yeah blocking
that information from children as
they're learning how to be humans that
won't have any costs
yeah
that won't have any costs this makes me
so [ __ ] angry
don't trust anyone over nine
maybe do it again he wasn't on you yet
oh
don't trust anyone over nine
all right yeah yeah
yeah a compelling response yeah i mean i
think anger is not a compelling response
but
these people
these people
um
i i have i have a perfect
a perfect way of describing them that i
am saving for
my next rap battle
and
your first one
yeah also my first but possibly quite
possibly my last one
and i heard 50 minutes okay um i've got
four more that i've that i've pinned or
that i've labeled here that we're going
to do one of them is just a comment we
will um
we'll get to these four one of which is
just a comment
brett that wasn't the comments that's
not it no no brett what is the
difference between intelligence and
consciousness
so much difference i know so much
difference um let's put it this way uh
you probably in your travels somewhere
in your social group know people who are
clearly very smart
and
not necessarily articulate about what
they know and maybe not even
necessarily inherently
aware of what they know but the their
cleverness is evident in what they do
right
um
so we've all seen people who can
innovate in some space
but not necessarily describe what
they're up to so i would just say our
definition of consciousness in our book
is that fraction of cognition that is
packaged for exchange and the idea is
that the conscious mind is built for
parallel processing it's built for two
minds or more minds to be plugged into
each other rather directly to exchange
abstractions so that the emergent
cognition is actually capable of more
than the sum of the individual
cognitions in question would be capable
of right that's a very particular
process and it works great for certain
stuff
and it has a personal manifestation the
fact that we have a consciousness that
can do that parallel processing trick
means that we also have that
consciousness on board when we're alone
and we can kind of have an argument with
ourselves and that works too but a lot
of what we do most of what we do is not
in earshot of that part of our minds and
um that does
i think you know those of us who have
turned out to be good at what the
conscious mind does at the abstractions
and the you know debating ideas back and
forth and the emergent cognition and all
of that tend to see it as the pinnacle
of intelligence and it's actually not
right in fact
in many ways it is the lesser right you
generate new stuff there you innovate
there but then once you've got it you
drive it into the layer that doesn't
have to think in this explicit kind of
terminology in order to get stuff done
and that's the place where all of the
glorious stuff that we marvel at on
reddit or
twitter or whatever we see you know cool
little snippets of people doing amazing
stuff right they're not thinking about
it at that point they're they're doing
it in some even more amazing way and so
anyway yes intelligence has a conscious
dimension for humans but most of it is
not conscious and um those of us who
default to the
because those of us who default to the
conscious also dominate the discussion
space because that is inherently about
consciousness i think we have um
shifted the definition in a self-serving
way and
um it makes sense
to uh
to recognize you know
in some ways i'm
uh recapping
something that is maybe even cliche at
this point but there's all kinds of
other genius and we tend to discount it
because it's harder to explain by its
very nature but but it's evident to us
when we see it and we all appreciate it
so
indeed
why are so few concerned with the
obvious slide into tyranny
well i think more people are concerned
that are letting on
i think that's one thing
i mentioned last week that i overheard
three
three liberal women
um
talking about what they were seeing
in the park uh and i was
heartened
by their observations and by knowing
that other people were seeing things and
um
you know it's hard to calibrate how much
what we're hearing what that means about
how how many other people are out there
thinking thinking some of the thoughts
that we're thinking
um
but we hear from a lot of people um
who are just grateful for the
conversation about the pointing out of
some of the inconsistencies and the
and the tyranny
um i'm going to go slightly more
mechanistic yeah
i'm going to borrow what i think is rahm
emanuel's
uh famous
unfortunate gaff uh
never let a good crisis go to waste
maybe that's not even roman manual but i
don't remember
in any case
i think there's a cognitive defect that
people have if you're not used to
thinking of
many dimensional complex systems kinds
of problems
then you may have commitments that are
good ones but they're too strong right
so the idea that there's a conflict
between let's say public health and
private health and that in order for the
public health to be well served um one
has to
accept
coercion let's say in
the private health realm right so you
may have to uh take a vaccine
um in order to drive a pathogen to
extinction or to get it controlled for
the good of everybody and if everybody
treats their own health individually we
don't reach a number that's useful and
people will die right right
okay
so once you say well the good people are
the ones that are willing to modify
their own behavior in favor of the game
theoretic of beating the um free rider
problem
okay but now if you say well that's just
simply true the good people are the
people who don't cause a free rider
problem by prioritizing their own health
over the public health
all right now you've just set up a
mechanism whereby you can be gamed if
somebody recognizes that you have that
as a sacred value then they may hand you
something in the guise of this is what
the good people will do in order to
serve the public health that may have
nothing to do with the public health i
mean this is an exact match for what
i've said
repeatedly on here that you know you say
wow this is a terrible thing person is
this is a terrible thing person b says
it sure is it's a really terrible thing
person a says therefore the solution is
x
person b says no it's a terrible thing
but i don't think your solution is going
to do it person a says if you don't
believe in solution x then you don't
believe this is a terrible thing so it's
exactly that same setup and you know
synonymizing recognition of big problem
with
solution can only be one thing is the
way that it is gamed and that it's it's
a tyrannical move it's it is quite
literally a tyrannical move yeah it is
one of the mechanisms of tyranny yeah
people who oppose x are free writers
um yeah and it's like
some of them are but
it is certainly not inherent to that
category and in fact that category is
multivariate um
and
so
in some sense i think in part people are
not
as
moved by the evident
advance of tyrannical
coercion because it has been
uh tightly bound to things that cause
them not to be able to see it for what
it is right yes and that's right um
when they do see it it's liable to be
too late
yeah it's a
it's a societal level situational
blindness it's like it's it's the
gorilla on the basketball court but done
at population level
right and you know the gorilla is
invisible on the basketball court for a
good reason right
in that case it seems like oh some
deadly thing could be hiding
uh in plain sight but the point is if
you were aware of everything that could
hide some deadly thing you'd never get
anything done because you're constantly
checking under the problem you don't see
the forest for the trees if you see all
the gorillas on every basketball court
right and so you know it's a trade-off
that on the average day pays handsomely
and occasionally
causes you to
miss something really important and
somebody
some entity some emergent property has
figured out how to exploit this to get
people to act against their own
interests while thinking that they are
right and you know here comes the um
totally expected straw man argument you
don't think gorillas are bad right like
i i said i want to recognize the
gorillas but i can't recognize all the
gorillas without failing to see bigger
themes ah then you don't believe in
gorillas
yeah it's it's a complete failure to
think in terms of trade-offs
actually it's a complete failure not to
think in terms of trade-offs you mean
it's a complete failure to to think in
terms of trade-offs
failure to think okay
sorry all right
and guerrillas missed a comma yeah by
the way don't think gorillas are bad
any of them ever
what are you sometimes mostly not i
mostly think gorillas are
pretty pretty innocent
okay
it's your funeral i guess
um
okay one more question and then we'll
wrap up with a very nice comment here
an ex-friend yelled out at me wear a
mask
at the cafe while i was sitting outdoors
safely please help
oh this is easy
um
what you do is you
you're about not to get help no this is
we'll see we'll see if you are about to
get the best advice of your life or no
advice
have you seen these really realistic
masks there's actually a very good video
circulating recently of these very
life-like masks that you can put on and
a young man can be an old woman in a
matter of
seconds it's amazing how high quality
these things are so i'm going to advise
you
it's pretty amazing okay
what i'm going to advise you is that you
look into these things and that you get
one made to look exactly like you okay
you put it on you go out with this
friend and when they say what's an
ex-friend
no make up
go out with this person
and when they say wear a mask you reach
down and you pull this thing off
i guarantee you you will give them
nightmares for the rest of their life
i was wearing a mask now look what
you've made me do
now was that good advice i think that it
was
um yeah you know there's this there's
this
paper that we talked about very early on
like april of 2020.
um
it couldn't have been that early maybe
it was ju it was it was early on last
year but that was based on like
i feel like hundreds of thousands at
least tens of thousands of cases of
covet and it was looking to see how and
under what circumstances had been
transmitted it was all out of china and
there was literally one case that could
be attributed to outdoor transmission
and um
we and that has that remains
no one has rebutted this and i actually
so i
don't have the paper in my head right
now i do cite it in this hospital she
left the
outside end piece on my sub stack on
natural selection so you can find it
there but um there's only more and more
and more evidence that so far
so far this virus is not transmitting
effectively outside now the one thing
that didn't come up when we were talking
about the white-tailed deer is
you know
presumably these deer aren't hanging out
inside right so the deer
seem to be if if if that study is what
it appears
then is it is transmitting between the
deer outside presumably um but that
doesn't mean that it is doing so in
humans there's been no rebuttal to that
paper there's been no retraction um
there's been just more and more evidence
in the same in the same direction that
actually being outside
is itself protective it just is yep now
we have we said at the beginning and i
think we need to reiterate each time we
talk about this that doesn't transmit
outside as far as we know there is
weird evidence
the portsmouth situation was largely
outside but it can't have been perfectly
outside i don't know what this is it's a
super spreader event um portsmouth
yeah um new hampshire yeah
okay
um in any case
it won't have been perfectly outside
there will have been things like
bathrooms and
places and i know that there were
previous cases where an outdoor wedding
was a super spreader event but it turned
out that there was an indoor bathroom
etc so everyone has to be very careful
with these things but what we would
expect as evolutionary biologists is
that if we don't treat this thing
carefully outside that it's going to
evolve this trick and we are going to
lose the best asset we have which we are
at the moment taking for granted but i
mean i'm actually i'm shocked
i mean we're now over a year and a half
into this thing and it doesn't seem to
have figured out this trick we hope and
you know as i said in that article on on
hospitals and outside air
you know last summer
it was it was really easy to to point
accusatory and appropriately accusatory
fingers at health professionals for
claiming that the real pandemic was
racism and that's what justified all of
these mass protests when you know the
day before when um people with the
opposite political bent were protesting
mass mandates and things like that well
then that was them you know putting
their lives at risk and obviously kovid
was the pandemic because that is what
the pandemic is um
and yet there don't seem to have been
super spreader events as a result of all
of those crazy protests no and in fact
right nor have there been um a lot of
problems within the homeless community
right interestingly right so both of
those things are not you know
not bomb proof evidence but both of
those
go in the direction of suggesting that
at least at that point and still we
haven't seen anything to to
go against this um this this virus just
isn't effective even you know those
protests were some of those radius were
massive and people were in very close
proximity and like the couple of times
we went down
to the courthouse downtown portland to
see what was going on and you know we
were trying to get you know out of you
know down street down wind of people
yelling right um we were trying to get
upwind of people yeah we were trying to
get out of downwind of people yelling
and it was hard like it was there was it
was there was a crush of people and it
was hard that didn't feel particularly
safe from a respiratory virus
perspective
and yet
you know i imagine
i imagine that some people got sick but
we never heard of any super spreader
events from these things right and we
actually when this was happening we said
you know people were leaping to the
conclusion that these blm protests were
going to cause super spreader events and
we said multiple times on dark horse
that's not so clear because as much as
you know there are two strikes here
right these are people closely packed
together actually three strikes in a way
which makes the metaphor bad but um
closely packed together
chanting
singing sort of
um
and uh and largely at night so the uv
value of being outside wasn't there but
nonetheless well the you know at least
in portland the thing you know the
protests reliably turned into riots at
night but you know most of the mass
protests
most of which were not riots across the
country and indeed the world were
daytime actually and they were evening
the sun was pretty low but anyway the
point is there were
there was only one thing that was
protective in those cases and that was
an outside environment which is
effectively infinite volume yeah right
but we said hey it's not clear that
these are going to be super spreader as
much as we're not in favor of these
protests they aren't what they appear to
be and they're dangerous especially here
in portland it's not clear that they're
you know a coveted danger because
they're outside yep yep and they don't
seem to have been
so finally someone from new zealand says
you're my sunday morning sermon love it
thank you
wow
uh so thank you yeah thank you for that
and um
thank you everyone for
all of your support and all of your
questions and i'm sorry there are so
many that we didn't uh get to
we had uh
we had some issues these last couple of
times and so the question period was
left open and we didn't see it and so um
there were even more questions this time
that we didn't get to because we tried
to feed in the ones from last time and
they were all sort of jumbled in
together
um
but we as usual as always really
appreciate
um all of your support and
i guess we encourage you to um to share
this video and when
if there are any particular clips out of
this that you are interested in put them
in the comments or send them to
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com and our
moderator will send them on to
our clip sky to make clips to put on the
dark horse podcast clips channel
subscribe to those channels both brett
weinstein and darko's podcast clips on
youtube and on odyssey
consider joining us at our patreons
where there's online a uh two hour
private q a once a month from the last
sunday of the month and brett has
conversations for a couple of hours a
couple times a month
for some of his patrons as well uh you
can find us
you can find our book at hunter
gatherers gatherersguide.com i think i
got that right um and me at
naturalselections.substance.com
and uh and we'll be back next week with
episode 93
and we'll be talking about school yeah
be the vitamin d that you want to see in
the world
that doesn't make any sense despite that
be good to the ones you love even when
they don't make sense
eat good food
and get outside let's get outside
[Music]
[Music]
you